hopefully the recording sucks for
everyone and I'll begin the
introductions
right hi everyone my name is Chong Chen
I'm one of the co-chairs of IDOC Global
uh for this year uh today we'll have an
expert briefing by Thomas Wiki who will
give a talk about the state of the art
of probabilistic programming all right
Thomas it's a long time open source
developer I'm one of the core developers
of Pi MC right and Thomas the floor is
yours
great thank you so much and thanks
everyone for tuning in
um of course of all days today the
internet uh died in my apartment so I'm
in a coffee shop I had to improvise last
seconds so apologies for any uh negative
impact that would result from that
um my video also becomes choppy I hope
someone will let me know
um
so yes I'm very excited to uh talk about
state of the art of probabilistic
programming today
um it's not always that I get the chance
to explain my view of how I think like
all these different things are connected
because there's a lot going on and a lot
of moving parts and it's all very
exciting but I think it can also be a
bit confusing so hopefully today we can
shine a bit of light on on these on on
what is happening
so
um
already was introduced but um I uh
studied cognitive neuroscience at Brown
before that I uh did my PhD in my
Master's in bioinformatics in tubing in
Germany uh that's where I grew up and
that's where I'm right now I'm in Berlin
Germany
and uh during my PhD I got really
interested in Bayesian modeling and uh
and pimec because I already loved coding
in Python and then got involved with
John salvatier and Chris Wallace back at
that time to write uh what was then
called pymph G3 which was
um the first one that was built on
theano and tensor Library
um as of two and a half years ago
um I uh with a couple of other very
talented open source developers
basically the the primec group we
launched uh Pine C Labs uh the basin
consultancy
um Twitter seems to uh seems to die down
so you can also follow me on Mastodon
based on clubs where the cool kids hang
out apparently
um so yeah so primary Labs I thought I'd
just give a brief introduction so uh as
I said we are the team that uh developed
it well a subset of that team right but
we formed out of the core development
team and I could be more excited about
the quality
um of of the people that that I get to
work with every day to solve some of the
most advanced
problems in Industry with Bayesian
modeling and of course use the resources
and the dedication we have to also of
course drive time C forward and in
general probabilistic programming as a
whole so
um this has been really interesting to
see also how business relates to that
and at the end I'm going to talk a
little bit more about that
so
um
uh yeah so that's uh that's a part of
the team
um Christian Lumen isn't on here but
he's also definitely a good part of the
um of the we like to call ourselves the
base in Avengers
um and that's that's how I think we
um we strive to be
um
so
uh recently I found this website called
starhistory.com and they allow you to
look at the history of GitHub Stars over
time for all kind of different
repositories and I thought it would be
interesting to compare
um how the some of the most popular
packages have fared over time and I
think it's quite interesting so uh
there's obviously Prime C here in in red
um the Stan there's pyro numpyro
tensorflow probability and touring Julia
package
and I mean overall I think this shows
that the
um the trend overall is is upwards and
it's really great to see that there's so
much interest in these Technologies and
overall that the
um that there are many new packages
right I think there's a lot of
innovation that can still be done and
new packages bring new ways of trying
things out so I think this is very
exciting
um obviously I'm also excited that like
uh pipe C string well
um however I like this is just GitHub
Stars right so I don't claim that this
is representative of uh I mean it's
represent of something I just don't know
what it is right
um for example I mean I would still
assume um that the the user base of Stan
is is larger than that of uh Pi MC and
obviously that's not represented here so
I think this is saying something but
yeah I don't think it's really uh
overall popularity or user base or or
how good a package is right it's
unrelated to that but I think it's
interesting
um to uh to look at where things are
headed
um so before diving into other things a
quick announcement out of the way
because I will be talking a lot about
this layer of the technology stack
um
so originally Pine C was built on theano
which was uh the first tense of tensor
Library out there before tensorflow and
uh pyro came along uh pytorch came along
and then the theater developed stopped
developing and that left us in a bit of
a pickle so
um with uh some the work of some Brave
individuals like Brandon Willett he took
thiano and forked it to uh Sarah and uh
basically overhauled the whole package
and like did really amazing work there
and and this is a lot of what I'll be
talking about the Innovation that is
coming from that layer
um however
um
we the pine C team have been
um trying uh have have really started
also to focus on that very same layer
because that's where a lot of the
Innovation really these days is coming
from as you'll see
um but there were sort of different
um I guess development philosophies and
also emphasis on like what technologies
uh should be pushed like obviously from
the pine C side we care about features
very specific to Prime C like for
example name dimensions and certain
optimizations that mainly mattered for
primec and
um that I guess shouldn't be really
included in Sarah which tries to be a
general purpose Computing package so
um basically we're trying to get the
Best of Both Worlds by
um taking our Sara and forking it to
what we call Pi tensor and then
um having Pi MC rely on that and then
sort of be able to innovate from both
directions right and like get more
development speed for the things that
really matter to Prime C
um
but nonetheless like amazing work by um
by the rsr team and it's what I'll talk
a lot about
um for the full announcement and some
more background you can go here
um so here is uh the first Trend that I
see which I think is really the most
exciting thing that's going on is uh
what I call uh the great uncoupling
where we can roughly categorize these
packages into
um different approaches
and I would say this uh for example the
monolithic approach right so there's a
very classic old packages the first ones
bugs but also modern packages that are
like really powerful like Stan obviously
and um they are uh I think both of them
are written in C plus and they write
their Standalone packages so they have
like some libraries but overall They
Don't Really they build like their own
technology stack like with the
computational block probability and
those kind of things
is mostly handled uh specific to that
library right
um
and
then I think the newer packages right
they try to
um move away from that and make use of
all these very powerful core
technologies that we have now which is
that tensor layer so obviously we have
uh pyro which Builds on pytorch we have
numpyro which Builds on Jax we have
tensor probability which was classic
built on tensorflow but they have also
now added a another back-end Jacks so
you can select in terms of probability
which one of those two backends you want
to use
and um and this is something that I
think is very powerful is to really
um detach all these different things
from each other and
um
and have them integrate and there's a
lot of power that comes from being able
to mix and match different Technologies
so pymc I think is like pushing this to
the extreme
um where I would call this then
multi-packet right so tensor world is
like has two back ends already but Pi MC
has
um well really three currently but this
in principle no limit to being able to
add them and uh so so basically I think
it's the approach of like trying to
build an ecosystem of different things
and this is what I meant in the
beginning when I said well this is all
very exciting right but if you look at
this it's like a whole bunch of stuff to
like know about and at Pine C we will
always try and make this accessible
through client C without you having to
know really what is happening underneath
all this uh but I think it's interesting
um even though it might be a bit
confusing um but that's what I'm gonna
try and explain
so obviously there's the Arby's package
which
um spawned out of pine C and
is uh providing like a back end for
storing samples and state-of-the-art
visualizations and that's
um that that is really cool and actually
also can interact with all these other
packages so
um being able to
uh Branch things out and then pull
resources around certain capabilities
that are shared across packages allowed
RVs to develop like capabilities that
were far beyond uh what we provided with
Prime C
and similar with uh Sarah or I guess Pi
tensor um
where uh that layer of abstraction
allowed to Target different compute
engines
and that includes jacks just like these
other ones but also includes number it
even includes piodite and I will be
talking about each of those and how
these things then interact
so I guess I haven't really talked about
how that really looks like but you can
think about this as PMC Pi MC being the
high level model description where this
is how you write the model with um nice
ux and UI and
then under the hood
um things happen uh where we build a
representation of the computation that
you're trying to do and usually there's
going to be the log probability but it
can be more it can be lock probability
and the sampler or variational inference
or just forward sampling right
and this probability graph
um
then can be optimized
um and there's all kinds of interesting
things and you can compute gradients
right so this is the idea of like
tensorflow and all of that but
oftentimes
um
these two things I married like
tensorflow for example right gives you
the graph engine but then also handles
like the compilation and execution of
that but I think it makes sense to try
and distinguish between those two so
with our star and Pi tensor you can
Target different backends
um so you can Target jacks or you can
compile that compute graph to number and
then execute it in number
um or the classic one of course that the
theology developers had included was
just C so they would just like write C
code
but there's also some part of that that
are in Python so really there are almost
no limits to what you can do and this
makes it future proof right because like
any new framework that comes out
um we'll just be able to write it back
and for it
um and
so as I said like this allows for some
really interesting combinations of
Technology
so for example
um
the using the Jax backend um there's a
very cool Library by Remy luff and uh
jumping Lao and some other developers
there's called blackjacks and it
provides influence algorithms written
directly in Jax so it has the nut
sampler it has
um Pathfinder which is like a new
variational inference method and a whole
studio of other very uh Advanced
state-of-the-art samples and entrance
algorithms
and
what is cool as well because it's
written in Jax right and pine C models
can be compiled to Jax we can just
interact directly at the Jax level so we
can plug those two things together
um and then have like a pure Jacks
program Jax graph that we can just give
to Jax and make it have low level
optimizations and have it make
um different execution engines right so
we can run it then on the CPU or the GPU
or the TPU and Pi MC is totally
oblivious to any of that complexity we
just ship it off to Jax which is like
designed for just that
and well why would you want to do that
um
well speed is probably the primarily
primary reason
um so Bayesian scaling of Bayesian
computation has always been a big Focus
um and something important and something
where like incredible progress has been
made over the last
um
five years basically any year like
there's been big strikes being made
um so with this like there's a blog post
I mean this isn't like a comprehensive
um Benchmark across models this is like
one model uh that uh we ran
and uh compared between Stan and pine C
without anything so this is the runtime
so lower is better
um on a like fairly sizable data set
um a Prime C compared to Prime C running
on Jax so this is actually using the
numpyro sampler but blackjacks gives
similar results uh but using only Jacks
right so now the sampling and the model
is happening at the Jax level
um and and that of course removes any
python overhead so there's speed up
coming from that and just jacks being
fast
and then as I said we can also run this
on the GPU uh which speeds things up
even more and then you can also run on
the GPU vectorize and that gives another
nice speed up so It won't always be
faster in our practical experience it
almost always makes it faster but it's
not a guarantee but it's so simple to
try out right this is the one line code
where you say well instead of sampling
um classically just sample on
um
um sample using Jax and and the
Blackjack sampler so very simple to just
try out and and for some models it makes
a big big difference
um but really the combinatorial space uh
there are very little limits so for
example there is
um
the nut pie sampler something which
Adrian zybold has written and I'm
personally very excited about
um and he wrote a nut sampler which is
the Workhorse of
um basically any big mcmc Library these
days
um in Rust and I personally don't really
know much about rust but
um he has improved the mass Matrix
adaptation so just the tuning of that
algorithm is is better but also it
allows to write very efficient simdi
code so vectorization
um is is happening in multi-threading
and all that good stuff and of course we
don't have a rust back end right
um only that sample is written in Rust
but
the number back end which we do have
through Sarah is
Computing the monologue p and
um and number is uh has a cool feature
where you can just get a c pointer right
so we just get something which we can
pass then to rust because rust can use
just a c pointer and then again remove
any python overhead and just get very
very fast execution and this seems to be
even faster than the Jax stuff probably
for two reasons I mean one is number
could be faster for that particular
model that we tried right so again these
aren't like comprehensive benchmarks
um but it just shows what is possible
um
but in this particular instance it took
sampling from 36 seconds to 0.5 seconds
so it was 70 times speed up which is
like insane right for again a one-line
code change so there's nothing the user
has to do
um you just like use different back-end
technology and all of a sudden like
things just start flying
um so this is very very exciting it's
still in the early stages experimental
but
um it works and it won't work on like
every model it still depends on like a
lot of work for number to be completely
supported but it's extremely promising
and definitely something that's
um starting to mature so check out not
Pi if you're interested in this
another cool thing that this approach
blouse is
um I sure I'm sure most of you have
heard of Pi script and piodite which
brings python to the web browser
and allows you to run python code
via webassembly which is a technology
which all browsers now support and
they essentially yeah compiled python to
webassembly and a lot of the other
packages so it's not that it's a small
subset but you can use numpy and pandas
and matplotlib and everything that you
need
and
thus because Pi MC also has a python
backend so you can just run in Python
just no one really does that because it
tends to be so slow but in this case
that's exactly what we need we want to
just compile the pi MC it's not really
compilation at this point right but it's
just running python code that computes
the mod monologue probability and then
executing that python code as you would
any other python code in piodight and
then you can run it in the browser so um
I thought I'd give a quick
um demo of what that looks like so here
I have a jupyter light and Jupiter light
is really awesome especially Jupiter but
also running completely in the web
browser so there's nothing on my machine
that's running you you can just go to
this website right yourself and it'll
bring this up and I can then pip install
uh micropy MC
um there's like a small modification we
have to do but in the future it'll be
easy to like do the standard pymc
package and then you import it and you
just write your PMC model this is a
simple beta binomial model you call
sample it'll tell you that there's no
compiler found right so it'll default
back to the python backend which is
exactly what we want and then samples
um
completely in the browser and it's
actually
um so I mean this is a very simple model
so um we can't really say too much about
speed yet but
um
it's not it's not embarrassingly slow
and of course we have access to all our
other libraries like Arby's too
and then plot things
uh so that's very cool
um so then other cool stuff
um
one thing that I thought was really neat
is
um Ricardo Vieira has implemented Auto
marginalization
um so often
when you have discrete parameters in
your model that makes it very hard
because you can't use samples like nuts
right so nuts only works on continuous
parameters
um so you can mix and match even though
that's sometimes a bit dicey and that's
not guaranteed to work but
um
ideally what you want to do is
marginalize out the discrete parameters
but that requires math and uh I'm very
lazy so and not that great at math so I
don't really want to have to do that
um so instead what this allows me then
to do is to
um Define different models so but so
this is just a different type thing that
has this capability I write the model
this is basically the switch point model
so we have a Time series and then a
discrete point in time where we switch
to a different
um time points or like the coal mining
disaster if you're familiar with that
but it doesn't really matter what the
model is
um just note that it has discrete
parameters
at the switch point
and
so we couldn't sample this with nuts
right
um but then we can just here called
marginalize and give it the parameters
that will not just over and it'll behind
the scenes basically do the
marginalization for us and then be able
to well if if that was the only discrete
parameter it is in this case
um but a sample this nuts and get a
better convergence and all of that so
um yeah this is again like very
experimental and early but uh well state
of the art right that's what we're here
for
and then
um
another cool thing is uh something I'm
personally also very excited about is
causal inference which has been getting
a lot of attention recently because it's
a very interesting approach to solving
many applied business problems right so
in marketing for example you have
campaigns you can't always run a B test
so you want to run quasi-experiments
essentially where you say okay well
um what would have happened if we had
and not run the campaign and then you
compare that to having run the campaign
and
and this causal inference framework is
very powerful and provides many
interesting ideas
um but oftentimes either uncertainty is
not really
um considered or it's coming from a
frequentist background
um and for a while I was actually quite
confused because both of them can build
dags right so what are the differences
but it turns out that there's many uh
similarities between Bayesian modeling
and causal inference and it makes a lot
of sense to try and combine The Best of
Both Worlds um to what then would be
called Bayesian called inference
and uh also very excited that um we just
released a new package called causal Pi
which uh there's a this book worked by
Ben Vincent
and he
um basically wrote like all of the
different methods that you can do like
differences within differences and
um
uh causal impact analysis uh all at your
fingertips and it doesn't marry you to
Bayesian framework like you can use the
frequencies framework so you can pass
inside models but you can also pass in
Bayesian models and then get of course
uncertainty in your content impact
analysis and has nice plots and all of
that so we're very excited about this
package
um definitely check it out and also Ben
is giving a talk
um at Pi data Global called what if
called reasoning means based inference
um here uh yeah check it out and also
check out the if you go to the primary
Labs website there's an announcement of
this package that goes into more detail
what this is so
um yeah I just this is like basically on
the statistical domain
and its last uh
um point
I also think it's very interesting to
consider where the business applications
of Bayesian modeling is headed so and
like with pipes Labs now uh with a very
unique position of really seeing
firsthand what people are using prime C
and probabilistic programming for and
the biggest applications that we've seen
are by far are in in marketing
um where for example we want to find out
what is the expected Revenue per
customer right so we have different
people sign up to our website and buying
stuff
um what is the expected lifetime value
of them and of course because we've got
basins we're getting posterior
distributions so this is uh one example
graph where for every customer on the
y-axis we get a posterior distribution
of what we think the lifetime value will
be for us
usually when you have business data you
have time service and oftentimes you
have spatial data so and very rarely are
these really modeled in the right way
way like really model the geospatial
structure
um but of course with pi MC and
um it's causing process support you can
build
geospatial models that model the spatial
distribution of your data um so yeah you
have like say marketing campaigns in
these different counties
um
he can model their similarities taking
the distances into account and that is
very powerful
um I already mentioned the causal
inference
um here especially marketing again if
you run campaigns this is something that
you really are interested in and of
course marketing attribution so you're
spending money on Google Facebook ads
all these different channels and you
want to know how effective they are in
driving the number of users and there's
a lot of work that we did at Pine slabs
with hello fresh for example
so definitely check out our blog for
many more
um information on these media mix models
so here's some pointers so primecio for
the open source project primary Labs IO
for our project drop in email
also quick announcement uh we are
running time C con
um as a web series this time so it's
going to be basically a conference
that's drawn out
um we're in a call for proposals
um that's about to end I think tomorrow
um so if you want to get in under the
wire that's fine if you want to wait
there will be another call for proposal
in um one or two months so this is not
something that's going to go away uh
we'd love to hear how you are using
prime C to solve all kinds of problems
um so this this will be really cool
um
and then also if you want to learn Basin
modeling uh together with Ravine Kumar
and alexandora we have launched an
introductory course called
intuitive-based uh intuitivebase.com
that really like without much math uh
skills required
um we try to teach you this in the most
intuitive applied way possible and uh
people seem to dig it so that we're very
happy about that there's also now an
advanced regression course that's
currently in beta that's going to come
out soon
um with Tommy carpeto Alex Andorra and
Ravine Kumar that also looks really
really cool so definitely check that out
so I talked for longer than I should
have I hope this was interesting I'm
very happy to uh any questions and start
opening up the discussion
excellent great uh thank you so much
Thomas very nice uh overview of MC and
the future of uh basic modeling uh I uh
so questions are welcome uh you can
either type your questions in a meeting
chat or
um I will allow participants to also
unmute yourself to ask any questions uh
feel free to use the uh I think there's
a reaction to to raise your hand if you
want to ask any questions and and I will
help Thomas field some of the questions
sorry
all right
um any questions so far from the
audience all right
um I have a question that was sent by
uh the direct message to me um I will
just ask you first in chat challenge
share comments to everyone
the question is are you working with
banks or insurers on Capital modeling
so
we are not
um and to be honest I'm a bit bummed out
by that because I think those two
problems that you named uh Prime
candidates for a Bayesian approach
um so
basically whenever you want to track
uncertainty because the decisions that
you're making have a risk right if
you're making decision making under
uncertainty base is going to be one of
the Prime examples and
so forth things like Capital modeling
um and and insurance right Premiere and
what are the risks uh I think it's the
Ideal tool
um I know that there are some people
using it but compared to marketing it
doesn't seem to be as embraced yet
um as I think it should be so
um yeah it's it's quite interesting to
compare these different Industries and
how eager they are to adopt
um this and I think there's reasons I
mean for why they haven't been embracing
it as much as for example marketing
um which which we can't talk about but
yeah so that's the answer
um we're not
all right yeah thanks for that uh
there's a second question in the chat
Thomas can you actually see the
questions as well in the meeting yes
yeah so
um tamash asks is there an overlap
between uh Sarah and Jax
um
so uh well yes and no
um so
where they live in the stack is
um
that arasara is a graph computation
library and
um busy focuses on on that layer like
having an abstract representation of a
compute graph and then doing stuff with
that and then
sending the ads to different backends
for computation and that could be Jax
right now
um there's definitely overlap in terms
of functionality right so you can't just
write
um a model
block probability in Jacks directly
right and you don't need Prime C or sort
of for that
um
and this is basically what numpyro does
so you can remove that layer and but you
can also
um yeah so and what you would lose by
that are like all the graph
um things that you can do on that
um if you have that layer
so um so yeah that's how I think about
it is like that's the execution layer
and then there's the graph
representation layer and those two
interact but and they have some
overlapping functionality but
um they're quite distinct and like
there's no difference in in code base
and
also in terms of the optimizations I
guess
um you can think of uh Sarah and Pi
tensor as being more high level in terms
of the optimizations that they're doing
and then Jax is very much focused on low
level optimizations in terms of okay
well now I know that I'm running on the
GPU so let me try and uh craft this
um the way that I'm executing this
specifically to run fast on gpus
so so that's what they're focusing on
and it um and if you combine them of
course you get optimization at both
levels right you get like a very
simplified compute graph that then also
gets executed in a very uh expedient
optimized way
thank you for that question
great thanks
um sure so
um there are a couple more questions in
a chat should I go through that first
before
someone unmuted themselves so there is
some question by semen Carstens
might be a bit too specific but how
General is the auto marginalization I
mean it likely doesn't actually solve
the marginalization integral numerically
so how can it work for arbitrary
distributions
right so it works in those cases where
you can easily enumerate through uh the
different options
um so yeah if it's like a more complex
integral where you need
um yeah numerical integration methods
that are not just summing
um that that won't work or if they're
not interdependent so it is
um quite limited but those cases are
quite common actually and
um
um and because they're quite common it's
actually nice to have that simple way of
just like throwing them out whether or
not really having to go through and
doing it manually even though it might
not be all that difficult to do manually
um yeah if you don't have to uh I'd
always take that so but yeah it's not
going to work on on all different cases
and especially not on complex ones
good all right thanks for that um the
next question is by Luke lewisboro has
playmc got any functionality for time
series model yet so like Dynamic linear
modeling common filtering Etc
um some but it's quite limited and this
is something that we're working to
remedy
um I think it's a a weak point of Pi MC
currently so there are things like
gaussian random walks uh ar1 uh Arn
processes
um
there's a garage thing uh but in terms
of like more advanced structural time
series
um those are not there yet there have
been some efforts to try and implement
this with Google sum of code and those
are headed in a good direction but
they're not done yet
um so uh for example if you compared
with tensor probability they have really
great support for all kinds of different
time series so they're definitely more
functional advanced than Prime C in this
regard
um
and
um also I would say so practically
speaking though most of the times
there's modeling that we're doing at
primary labs for example is done using
calcium processes so we personally
didn't really have the need just because
for us custom processes are the
Workhorse that we do almost everything
with that's time varying
um because they have like all this
flexibility in terms of like
um including
structure like seasonality and really
crafting the kernel to the problem uh
now it's not going to work for every
time series problem like those
structural time series models have their
place and we want to add them
um so but currently it's only uh
rudimentary I'd say but uh contributions
will come and it's something they were
working on
that's a good thick way to the next
question which is related to
contributions uh the question by Emil
dimitrov uh do you encourage and work
with external bodies to contribute to
the pi MC software Universe for example
what about developing a new sampler that
uses a quantum computer as a backend
yeah
um yeah that's that's cool stuff so
um
I mean we we love collaboration I mean
this is really
um what we're about at Pine C is
building a collaborative environment and
fostering Community efforts
um so and actually I have been contacted
just privately by
um at least two different startups that
were in the quantum Computing space and
I know next to nothing about this
technology
um but they explain it to me a little
bit and it sounded really interesting
and
um especially though it seems like it's
geared towards a discrete models so if
um because quantum computers I guess at
the core are discrete and you can just
like evaluate a whole bunch of like
States in parallel very fast
um now at pimsy Labs we almost don't
have any discrete models it's very uh
and I'm
it's very rare for us to encounter
discrete problems I don't know
why that is it just seems that most of
the problems people are using that for
are continuous and
um yeah so
um so that is I think that's very
interesting
um as it all but I also had the sense
that it was still I don't know five to
ten years in
um in the making so
um promising cool happy to chat
um but but not
not on the on the map yet
yeah excellent thanks for that I I think
on in my very rudimentary knowledge of
our content Computing the hardware
itself is uh uh is space hungry to have
lots of space and now they mainly work
with emulations or like a hybrid
Computing kind of style between content
Computing and also your regular HPC
systems anyway but that's my very um
cost screen knowledge the next question
is by
francescob uh the question is it feels
like the library is moving very fast is
the documentation learning resources or
examples keeping the same fast pace
um well thanks for perceiving it as fast
we're trying to push it as much as we
can
um and uh so yeah documentation learning
resources example is something that is
like very important to us so we try to
not only make a great package that is
fast and scalable and advanced but also
user-friendly and and nice to use and
beginner friendly and also a great
teaching tool so
um
and then really using that to uh well
teach people Bayesian modeling right so
this is definitely a big part of our
efforts
and
um I I'm a huge fan of like the pine C
examples page so if you go to Pine cro
right there's like a big list of
um of notebooks and it's a lot of work
to keep those up to date
um and but there's a lot of people
working on it so we have a whole uh
basically we have a docs team and we
have a community team
um and both of those are basically go
out fostering the community but also
making sure that the docs and uh
uriolabriel is like uh very very active
with the website and uh driving efforts
and dockathons and uh getting to
community engaged and there's a lot in
um in terms of efforts of getting people
involved in these efforts to keep things
up to date because those are like great
entry points for people who don't really
know too much about the core Library uh
but fixing a notebook to like
um use a new feature in pi MC that's
something that's much simpler uh but
just as valuable as like
um things like Auto marginalization so
uh yeah there's um a lot that we're
doing in this regard and a great entry
point so uh yeah I think reshma has
posted a link uh in chat uh with some uh
with a contributor guide of how to do
that
um so yeah and it so I mean we're not
perfect in that regard but I think we're
pretty good um so things do keep up and
um and we uh we think it's very
important that they do
but
um thanks for that and I'm very happy to
see the communities alive and very
passionate about contributing to the uh
privacy software so um uh the next
question uh let me see
uh Russia thanks thanks for helping to
answer that question yes but the
question was if one wanted to contribute
to PMC code basis is it beginner
friendly
um I know a little by Asian but by no
means an expert and there are two
YouTube links and that Russia is shared
um to help begin the contributors
contributed by MC so thank you for that
I remember Thomas on your last slide if
you want to learn about about Bayesian
as well there is a link that you shared
um perhaps uh uh would you make your
slides available for for the audience
yes absolutely yeah yeah
um
first issue to work on which is video
time steps
oh yeah
um so yeah reshma is um
one of the core members of the community
team and really driving a lot of efforts
in in this regard and um
um also associated with data umbrella
who like just is an amazing Organization
for doing these community events and
really getting people with little
experience on board and
um and helping with uh yeah like
hackathons and Dr thorns and webinars
and those type of things and uh yeah so
and I mean the question was about the
pine C code base so
um
yes in terms of like someone who's
motivated to contribute I mean a that's
amazing we are very excited
um about anyone who wants to contribute
um and uh the question is always well
where to start so that's a good question
and
um it depends a bit I mean mainly I
think it depends on what you personally
are excited about so if you are like
well I love the sampler stuff
um probably you want to start
contributing there
um or like I really like writing
examples right that's that's cool too or
I love compilers right then you might
want to check out the asara project or
the pi tensor project
um
and
um yeah so
um but definitely in terms of like
beginner friendliness
um the examples
um and the resource that rationalize
shared are great and the code base I
mean we try to keep it uh beginner
friendly
um it's actually not that bad because a
lot of the complexity is being pushed to
the
tensor back end
um so really the code there is a lot of
the math stuff and a lot of the glue
that holds things together so I'd say
the code base is approachable but I mean
of course it's a
technical package
um and and and the library is fairly big
now uh but um yeah we're we're happy to
help
um so uh just check out the issue
tracker uh there are beginner friendly
issues that um you can always pick up
too so that's more the developer route
great excellent uh thanks for clarifying
that ah and it's just a restaurant I
wrote that there's a data umbrella event
today on RV's the plotting Library so
there's also uh I mean just an amazing
place to contribute to uh it's an
amazing Library
um so if you like visualizations and
plotting uh that's a great place so yeah
there's a Meetup data umbrella events
thing
indeed uh thanks for that uh so they'll
see
making sure I didn't miss a question the
next question is
Mr from early answers with this talks
recording be shared uh yes it will be
uploaded to the I did a global uh 2020
to produce on YouTube
um so yes you will get the recordings of
this on YouTube
all right you're welcome
we still have uh 15 minutes left of this
um one hour slot
um are there any other questions for
others you feel free to also unmute
yourself
uh if you would like to ask a question
verbally if you if you don't want to
type it in chat
um
also if you want
um if you don't have a question but
would just like to share uh like briefly
a problem that you found Pi MC to be
useful for uh I personally would be very
interested I think many other people as
well like these user stories
um I always find it inspiring so
the the floor is yours
excellent suggestion
does anyone have a use case in mind
working on or planning to work on
perhaps not yet
okay
that's fine
um
cool
well I guess if there's no more
questions
um
we can wrap it up I mean there's many
ways to get in touch with me and Us in
general uh so there is the Prime C and
Pine's Labs Twitter I'm T weekly on
Twitter and mustard on
um timecio has like all the resources
pimeter labs.io has uh a lot of other
resources and if you have any modeling
needs
um or new work for a company where you
think like a corporate Workshop would be
cool uh we do that as well so super
happy to uh subscribe to chat thanks
everyone
excellent all right thanks Thomas oh
stop the recording now